are you doing guys welcome to the second
edition of the all-new Reuben report I
have two of my favorite people making
their all-new Reuben report debuts
Jacqueline glen and whitney mixter you
guys have been on the show probably as
much as anyone else so it was important
to get you guys in here quick
thank you yeah what do you think of our
new digs what yeah I feel like I'm in my
like smoking then like I'm about to go
on an adventure yeah it's not it's not
too masculine for you I mean I don't
know if it's masculine and Jaclyn would
you say too masculine for you masculine
just enough it's your show it's my show
man all right well it is my show so
let's get right to it
you guys have all heard the new
McDonald's slogan I'm loving it with the
cow according to a recent know from
Janney Capital Markets the fast food
giant will soon enter a scale is one of
its ingredients the no ads possibilities
include kale for you some salads or
perhaps a kale smoothie and we're
generally McDonald's clearly aims to
raise consumers perceptions of the
quality of its food all right so I eat a
ton of kale I do a kale shake every
morning kale Caesar salads
I love the kale kale and McDonald's
something doesn't seem quite right
why because it's healthy yeah healthy
McDonald's what's going on here they
must be up to no good right I mean hey
if it's can I get people to eat
healthier than I want for it yet
this is like yet another like health
food that they can just paint into
something unhealthy like it took yogurt
and we made it unhealthy we took
vegetables and apple slices and made
them unhealthy now we're going to take
Kalin head-on yeah are they gonna fry
kale like that's where this is all going
right because don't people go isn't the
whole point of going to McDonald's not
for health like they're trying to trick
us into thinking you're gonna walk out
of there feeling better but that's not
the point of McDonald's right the
blinding that it's food so the point of
it is to eat you know so if we could get
people to do that in a healthier way
then I don't think that's such a bad
thing but I don't think a little bit of
kale on Big Mac is gonna make a big
difference yeah I mean they're major but
they're they're pulling some
major double standard here because I
don't know if you remember a little
while back they literally came out and
had it juicy burger and made a statement
you can't get this kind of juice from
soy or quinoa and this isn't chaos of
green wait skirt kale sells really well
this is actually a delicious quinoa
burger drizzled in a like a nice fresh
kale sauce yeah but just to clarify
we're saying literally that was like a
month ago they were mocking kale and
then the kale people must have got to
the right and now they're they're Pro
kale so we should you want to give
McDonald's credit I can see what's going
on here trying to give them credit I'm
just saying if that you know I'm sure
it's a marketing ploy yes but at the
same time it's a good one you know it's
something that's gonna be good for
people and I mean I know that they were
very hypocritical because I didn't see
that commercial yeah they were just like
hey you know this is obviously not gonna
because this is big and fat and greasy
yeah unhealthy food yay but now they're
starting to put it in there and I'm not
gonna really complain because it's like
kind of like in my mind somebody saying
I'm not gonna ever donate to charity now
I am no you can't because you said you
were going to it's like okay I'm right
let that go so I know we're in LA here
I've had you guys on the show a million
times we do a lot about food and people
eating healthier and trying to source
food locally and all that stuff but
there is a place for McDonald's in this
kind of stuff right do you ever get that
craving like suddenly you're like I've
got to eat something from a fancy and
Hawk McDonald's or usually had several
cocktails so that's what it for you it's
like the drunken yeah like if I'm drunk
like late at night which never happens
by the way you know sometimes I like
that incredibly shiny bun like I like to
be able to see myself reflection and the
fish filet but like that's what I like
yeah yeah do you ever feel it coming out
of you that's what I eat it very rarely
now maybe like once every three months
McDonald's I would I do it I can
actually feel it I think I never feel it
coming out of me like just I think it's
still in there yeah how often do you go
to the guilty route I'd I mean it's hard
for me cuz I'm a vegetarian so a lot of
fun oh you were a vegetarian after all
this time I don't know
a lot of fast food places aren't an
option yeah so what is it well I guess
you could go to like in and out they do
like you get like a bun with some
lettuce yeah but so you can't so you do
nothing in it I guess you could do it
right I'm not really a shake shakes are
awesome you want a kale shake for
McDonald's I don't know if I want to
catch it for me guys like it should've
been like actually blending it in with
the ice cream ice cream there you go all
right what do you guys think Cal
McDonald's is it a big marketing ploy or
they actually make us healthier let us
know in the comments right down below
all of my female heroes were Golden
Girls until I came across this lady
Lassa Lassa Lassa en el balcón fiesta
remote Abedin
open a Milwaukee loop all right so just
to set that up a little better for you
that is a Lebanese TV show and obviously
the host is stepping up not only for
herself but for all women and women's
rights which that part of the world not
doing that well when it comes to women's
rights this is a beautiful thing
yeah that guy made me very angry yeah
beneath me to be talked to by a woman
it's like excuse me yeah it's hard to
believe that that's actually still going
on this is 2015 yeah and it's a
professional setting it's what she does
for a living you know it's like a normal
thing for guys to come on the show and
be interviewed by her and what he thinks
he's special or something it's like yeah
that's problem shouldn't we give this
girl major props like this kind of went
viral a little bit but I feel like this
is the type of thing with everything
going on in the Middle East
women's rights just disastrous all over
the place like she's really putting her
stuff on the line right there I mean and
I think that's half the problem why it
hasn't gone incredibly viral like to the
next level because I mean there's still
a risk factor for this woman's life
right feeling absolutely
unfortunately I mean I am kudos to him I
mean I look up to her tremendously that
was very bold of her I love how he
literally is at a loss for words
literally pauses like way Hoda yes just
happen and and he literally said it like
that how does that shoot does she like
have a private like plug that she can
pull because it seems like she's just
like saying yeah it wasn't like
production or anything like that like
she actually pulls his his audio
yourself or she's got an audio that it's
just a chick probably the other side
why are we so okay with women's rights
being so backwards in this part of the
world like I feel like if this happened
in Europe or something it wouldn't be
okay but over there or even if happened
in America this would never be okay to
speak to a woman like that but we we
just allow it I don't know what we're
supposed to do as I say with all these
Middle East things I'm not saying we
should do anything but like what can we
do - I'm open I'm not okay with it yeah
yeah we can know yeah I mean I think
this is good that we're talking about it
yeah I mean it's kind of hard to do
anything else we don't really have a lot
of control over what they're doing I
think I let people just see it as the
norm yeah yeah and I'm like well that's
just how it is over there and they blow
it off but I mean that's totally not
acceptable so I think the only thing we
can do is you know this video on YouTube
was awesome it's getting millions of
views that's awesome you know and then
we're talking about it yeah so yeah
shouldn't eights groups though be like
like code pink or whatever the other
woman's right I know code pink though
it's all about war with that but like
shouldn't they be like finding this
woman and being like this is gonna be
the face of our new campaign for women
across the world absolutely but I think
she's right I think that you know it's
so it's thought to be such the norm and
that culture that a lot of people in the
United States and and in Europe I think
just think it's like something that is
built into their religious constructs so
they don't want to mess with it or they
don't know it
to kind of challenge it which is
incorrect yeah this stuff like this make
you guys think like how good we actually
have it here like I know we're not quite
there on gay rights yet we're still not
there with women's rights with a lot of
things but like when you see things like
that really realize like it's pretty
good here right I mean it makes me think
it's pretty good at the same time I
don't want to think oh we've got it
pretty good I think that should just be
universally had we just want full
equality agree and I feel like a lot of
people will use these types of
situations to be like well you shouldn't
complain about anything you have in the
United States because look how much
worse it could be yeah you know so I
think that it's important to like you
know keep your good perspective on
everything and it's important to talk
about other countries but also you know
doesn't mean you need to lose sight of
problems we still have here all right so
I did a segment with you a couple weeks
ago at Roseanne's about whether you are
a feminist or not so I'll start with you
on this one do you consider yourself a
feminist I mean in the literal sense if
you look in the dictionary and look up
what feminism is I would consider myself
that I would also consider myself more
than a feminist and egalitarian like I
just want to be considered a human who
wants equal rights and demands accords
across the board yes that was pretty
solid
I want to clap for that answer yeah yes
that's pretty much what we said in our
video you know because like by the
dictionary definition and of course
women's rights right why would you say
anything differently right but a lot of
times you know modern feminism things
have taken a weird turn and is turned
into this man-hating right culture which
I don't want to identify with there's a
lot of reason ism is there one of it
right yeah all right well what do you
think are you guys feminist should we
take this woman and really be making her
sort of the face of how we can change
things in the Middle East and for
women's rights all over the place to let
us know in the comments right down below
porn pyramids preposterous probably the
ten minute long video is actually shot
last year but recently found fame when a
local paper published a report about the
video paired with screen shots from the
film officials originally denied the
film's authenticity but have since
changed course
all right so I've been to Egypt I've
been to the pyramids there actually
while they are incredible absolutely
incredible astounding to look at there's
not that much going on there actually
unfortunately
exactly now there is but the British
actually took most of the stuff like
that that's all in the British Museum's
but this part of the world isn't this
what they need more than anything else
we were just talking about women in this
part of the world but don't they need to
be okay with sex like to me that seems
like the linchpin that will if you get
if you get that how we might start
getting okay with everything else yeah
they need it but I mean this is like a
very it's like zero to you know a
hundred type of like be okay with this
porn that's something that you consider
to be kind of special yeah so you think
that's too much I thought you were gonna
say that you were okay with sort of like
push I mean like I would love for them
to be more open about sex and sexuality
and you know rights and all that but I
think that this is just gonna push them
in the exact opposite direction yeah
yeah I mean being like but are you okay
with this I just picture like a lot of
family photos and family albums like
having like really awkward backdrops you
know with like different positions in
the back like what did you do on your
vacation
I don't know and what was that like
awkward nip slip that she has like that
was that the flashing no I think you got
a little bit God there was full sex yeah
if you know where the actual just want
to be able to talk about it with more
you know yeah you're you're a pro and
you want to research the topics
appropriately and I appreciate that with
everyone walking around we're all
walking around with cameras and phones
and all this we should expect this stuff
like doing there will be any place
that's really considered a holy site
like five more years from now there's
gonna be porn shot pretty much
everywhere right I mean I think so and I
mean why not like it you know I think
there's gonna be like porn in the
Vatican I mean they're actually probably
doing it but it's not being recorded
really awful and illegal as open-minded
and pro body and sex as I am like it's
still like you gotta keep some things a
little off yeah you gotta keep something
a little
protected like family attractions yeah
right have some respect so even though
that was my one conservative yeah that
was the most conservative thing so
you're saying that even though the
pyramids aren't a religious thing so but
you're just saying as a National
Monument kind of thing yeah most likely
there are children there yeah do you
think that do you think this is a little
bit of it feeds the idea to the people
there that the West is evil see you see
what they do they come over here rushing
before like it's it's like push them in
the opposite direction it's too much you
know yeah I really thought you're gonna
be you know there's a balance to things
yeah so so the porn people the people
that hate porn then you're serially
watching the most more night is that I
mean yeah they're usually the ones
secretly in the form they're in the bore
that you can't find you know what do you
make of the porn people there there's a
through line here with fundamentalism
find people that are fighting against
something are the people that are doing
it behind closed doors yeah I mean I
think people are just afraid of these
types of things like it just scares them
I think it's horrible and evil even
though they secretly kind of like it if
you're like someone that someone is
judging them so they have to not like it
even though they kind of do yeah well
we're judging you people unless you
comment right down below it's not TV
it's HBO now get ready to stream Game of
Thrones on all your Apple devices Apple
and HBO announced the new service called
HBO now that will not require a
traditional TV subscription and will be
available exclusively on Apple devices
what it makes its debut in early April
the service will cost $14.99 well worth
it to see Arya Stark become more badass
every week alright so we've done a bunch
on the show about cutting the cable I
did cut the cable for like a year and
then I'm embarrassed to say that over
the last couple of months I realized I
still need cable news just to know what
I'm talking about I can't believe that
so I'm back on which feels like a drug
addict like going back to the dress
feeling very shame right now but if HBO
is doing this like if HBO is officially
like we don't need you cable companies
anymore
the cable companies is it over for the
cable companies
I think it's gonna hurt I mean a lot of
my friends that do still have cable only
do it for HBO yeah their favorite shows
are on HBO Game of Thrones for example
and they don't you know really need any
of the other channels what a bunch of
reality TV that they're not interested
in at least a lot of my friends they
just want like the movie quality like
shows yeah and now they can get that
without cable so you're off the cable
I'm not you're off for you good for you
I'm still on like you or the cable deals
trying when you say that though like
you're know cuz I love cooking shows and
I'll say yeah I'm say it in public
cooking shows and there's no off the
cable a bundle package yet for those
types of people so um you know but I do
have my Apple TV and I love it and I
have the Smart TV that links to Netflix
yeah
the thing about this though I'm not
impressed with this at all it's 14.99
that's double the price of Netflix yeah
and they're and they're pairing up with
Apple and cutting out a huge market for
other things and I just feel like it's
kind of like the they've become like the
Mean Girls of the cord cutters they're
like you we're really cool and you're
right they're gonna come with us you're
gonna go there and you're really
essentially only paying $14.99 a month
for Game of Thrones the movies you can
get on Netflix I'm sorry all right so
it's basically for Game of Thrones is
there anything that's what I was looking
at this I was like what else is actually
on HBO right now yeah six other cities
not all right that's yeah I've never
been in HBO I to be honest I feel more
shamed by saying I've never seen Game of
Thrones
you've never seen Game of Thrones wow
that's you're gonna get a lot of if
you've seen some of the Isis beheading
videos it's basically it's basically the
same thing but I think you make an
interesting point about Apple do you
feel like Apple is going to control
absolutely everything we did a story a
couple weeks ago about how they're
secretly have been building an electric
car so they're coming after Tesla soon
we're all walking around with this stuff
in our I have an iPhone and iPad I've
MacBook everything like they're gonna
just own us I don't think that's a
permanent thing though the Apple I think
that's one like for three months and
then they're gonna bring yeah other
things yeah it's like a start-up kind of
things yeah I'm not two square do you
hear that Apple in general is booked
sort of too powerful they're building
this like I wouldn't really complain
yeah what do you think that's the thing
I love Apple like I feel like I can
somehow walk through the folds of time
with Apple products like I feel like I
could design things like there's
programs I have no idea what I'm even
doing but like if I have them on my
computer I feel like I'm at least making
a start
yeah final thought on this and I think
we got your answer already what are you
watching what are you actually watching
these days oh my gosh I don't really
watch very much tea i watch youtube
videos and there's the ribbon report DUI
ruin report you watch YouTube back on
slash cackling Glenn what else do you
work I don't watch the light you know
you hate that but the music channel you
like yeah that's okay whatever that's
like a little thing on the side anything
yeah I mean pretty much I don't watch
very much TV though in general all I
watched Downton Abbey and Walking Dead
which is probably the two most polar
opposite like one is a period piece
where it's Pleasant and lovely and
wonderful and English and Renaissance
was horrible murder and bloody gore and
you know anyway what are you guys
watching have you cut the cord what do
you make HBO's move let us know in the
comments right down below are you a
believer that atheists are treated
fairly all crime Alpana wants to do is
leave Egypt the 23 year old engineering
student was facing three years in prison
for believing in nothing al banna is an
atheist who is facing charges for
insulting Islam with his atheism he told
AFP all I want now is to leave Egypt
life is not possible for a theist here
between 2011 and 2013 forty-two
defendants faced with the same charges
were ruled guilty all right so I've got
a ton of stories on atheist and we've
talked obviously many many times about
atheism you are my number one atheist so
you must represent all atheists Santa
Maria is gonna be pissed you're you're
right there 101a
I feel like atheists are under attack in
a different way in the last like year or
so that's a lot in the United States but
of course all over the world right what
what is people's problems with atheists
they take it as a personal insult if you
don't agree with them on
particular subject and that's exactly
what's happening this guy you know he's
an atheist and they're saying that is an
insult to Islam right but what about
that whole tolerance with religion thing
yeah that's supposed to be a thing right
yeah and the thing is is it's against
any of the three major Abrahamic
religions it's Christianity Judaism and
Islam yeah so if you were a Christian
over there it wouldn't be an insult but
being an atheist well you have to
believe in something so if you don't
believe in anything that's somehow oh
that's it that's an interesting take so
it right to be an atheist would be the
equivalent of being just some other
religion to say you should be equally
mad at that but they are but they're not
if you guys it's almost like if you have
something it's better than nothing
because at least you're a part of a
group similar to mine yeah I mean what
do you think I feel like atheists are
just constantly under attack I see this
in the media all the time on Twitter all
the time people are always attacking New
Atheists which i think is so weird
because atheists generally pretty good
people not doing they're not having a
lot of rallies right stoking up the
hatred right no I think I think similar
to what she said I think that you know
people feel personally attacked because
it's removing people's kind of
last-ditch effort at hope at like this
possibility that there's something else
it's like they don't want that
possibility to be taken away from them
so it hurts them you know I really and
they take it very personally yeah I know
we did a story on this also which will
annotate above but can you explain the
difference between atheists give me some
basic definitions of atheist and theist
and agnostic can you give me a little
something here cuz people always every
time we do with something on this people
start arguing about just actually what
the words mean right and that's very
frustrating for me too because a lot of
people think that being an atheist means
that you know there is no God absolutely
100 percent sure certain and you have to
say you have it yes I'm very angry about
it always yeah but that's not what it
means at all it just means that you
don't believe in God and it doesn't mean
that you know anything because that's
what agnostic is that's where that comes
in because Gnostic the root of that word
is just it means knowledge so to have to
be agnostic means you don't have
knowledge of something so I can say that
I'm agnostic I don't have knowledge of
whether or not there's a God but I'm
also an atheist so it's
yes so you're an agnostic agnostic
atheist because you acknowledge you
don't know and then be that not knowing
you're saying you don't believe right
and I feel like everyone should
technically say that right yeah that's
I'm gonna ask you do most a theist call
themselves agnostic yes well you know
that I talk to you yeah yeah why can't
we get more tolerance out of religion
every religion why is it not just about
the atheism thing but in general why you
know religions supposed to be tolerant
and yet we see so much war and hatred
and whatever always fermented I mean
because since the beginning of time
we've used religion as a scapegoat for a
barrage of other things whether it be
power or money or fear or things like
that you know it's just used as a tool
so I don't think that you know I just
feel like being like I said before
saying you're an atheist removes that
power to control and that power to have
that tool that's been used since the
beginning yeah is this the weird thing
about social media and Facebook and all
that like on one hand it's like freeing
us all and it created the Arab Spring
and like has literally taken down
governments so it's amazing what it's
done in that part of the world and then
on the other hand now we're seeing the
backlash to it which is that this guy in
Egypt Egypt and how high of ours they
get out the second-most aid of any
country in the world from the United
States is being persecuted for atheism
so it's a double-edged sword with social
media - right
yeah I mean it can be and it's just it's
unfortunate that in any situation he's
in a country that's not accepting of
that but overall I feel like it's
important to have social media because
we can you know make positive change
through it yeah the atheists need to be
more outraged like you're being very
calm right now this is one of you are
beautiful right like being attacked yeah
this is not uncommon yeah I mean I hear
stuff like this all of the time yeah I
mean as much as it does make me mad and
angry it's just like one more thing you
know telling me and everyone else that's
an easy that is an atheist that you're
not okay that you're not normal that
you're somehow insulting others you're
like you're almost like over the outrage
that's what I said I mean like yeah I've
calmed down a lot one of my first her
doing videos on YouTube I was like girl
very angry and yeah cussing but now I'm
a little bit more like okay I've been
talking about this for like four years
now
ya know like what's new ya Whitney I
feel like we need to play a game like
how to piss off an a this is a sound
we're sandwiching you with everybody
sister now is the thing is that it's an
impossible battle to win because there's
just no proof in any directions just so
we can sit here and just be get the
maddening you know you can just like
lose our minds over it so there's really
nothing you can do yeah is there nothing
you can do I know one thing you can do
you can comment Y down below
Danica Patrick is gonna have some new
competition uber announced on Tuesday
night is creating 1 million jobs for
women by 2020 according to Mashable the
initiative is the result of a
partnership with un women a United
Nations organization committed to global
gender equality a mission that can only
be accomplished when all women have
direct access to safe and equitable
earning opportunities alright more women
bird drivers that seems good to me I
personally don't care whether my uber
driver is a man or a woman or something
in between or from another planet
doesn't really matter as long as they
get me to where I'm going but I do think
it's sort of interesting as women do you
guys feel when you hop in an uber do you
feel safer if it's a woman driver I mean
most of my uber drivers have been women
really yes that's kind of like I've been
listening to this story and I was like
what is that not already happening
that's interesting I think maybe la our
sense of what's going on with uber and
the bigger thing is being skewed I and I
do feel like every time I get in the car
and it's a woman I'm like a little bit
relieved because I've had some creepy
experiences with dudes and it's just
like I like to not have to worry about
that yeah what about you I honestly
don't think about it either way for some
reason I swear living in New York and
taking endless amounts of taxicabs has
built up this false sense of I will
never get in an accident in this car it
doesn't matter how bad they're driving
I'm not gonna wear my seatbelt even
though I wear it every in every other
car right I don't know why that is
that's interesting though so you took it
to a place of like some idea of like
maybe women or worse drivers but I think
most people fear it more that if a woman
gets in the car that the man is like a
pervert yeah you know you're definitely
not worried yeah so you but you meant it
more for like is this guy like a weirdo
yes sir Lee that guy's might be better
driver I don't
yeah the driving is hopefully they all
can drive drive since there were drivers
yeah but ya know I've just had some kind
of creepy guys I'm like with a group of
friends it doesn't matter yeah if I'm
going somewhere on my own I'd rather it
be a girl driving but I mean it's it is
what it isn't
yeah to your point about the taxi
drivers like sometimes I get in an uber
and it's so pleasant and it smells nice
and I was in one last night and the guy
had all these lollipops and told me of
water and all this stuff and chocolate
and then every now and again I don't
think boy I do miss like an
old-fashioned New York City dirty gross
smelly sweat like like you was having to
lay a plastic bag over it essentially
drive on like puke over there like some
other bodily fluid like there's
something like about it that I kind of
miss is that totally happy
well that sounds very weird - lollipop
it's just it's like stepping into a
magical fairy land I'm like what do you
have chocolate normally even eat this
stuff but I want a lollipop I wasn't and
over because he had a whole barrel like
an actual barrel of candy I'm like I
want to like throw it off by itself but
then you gave him five stars than you
were whatever the match started yeah
really be horrible for me - give us some
time yeah you know I got a new bird
picked me up once and the guy said to me
that he almost didn't pick me up because
I didn't have as a user I didn't have
like the max stars like what what did I
do what I don't know what I cuz usually
I'm pretty quiet like I don't talk that
much of them yeah outside waiting I try
I try to I try to be final thought on
this what do you think for the people
that I know that some people are gonna
watch this and say well men are just
better drivers that's just how it is men
are better drivers women are nervous
behind the wheel Burke murdered Turner
say something to those people I mean I'm
a good driver Hey no no I mean that's
that's
stereotype that's it I think yeah well I
mean the fact is I mean woman's
insurance rates are lower for a reason
you know also I would like to just throw
in the fact that this is an incredibly
smart move for uber because they're
aiming number one they're partnering
with the UN like what they're taking
right sure and then taking over the
world
I'm so confused but you know there are
eight ways to have 1 million female
drivers in the next you know couple
years whatever that's and and they're
saying that currently it's 14% of their
drivers or women so that means they're
basically aiming to have 8 million plus
drivers total in a couple years they're
just going to take over the roads I mean
this is a really smart Avenue approach
to take I think I just did all that math
in my head a lot of math anyway
do you like lollipops let us know in the
comments right down below they say
elephants have great memories but they
can soon forget about being in circuses
the 13 elephants that are now part of
the Ringling Brothers shows we sent to
the circuses Center for elephant
conservation in Florida joining over 40
others Kenna field chairman and CEO a
few entertainment said when we did so we
knew we would play a critical role in
saving the endangered Asian elephant for
future generations I literally remember
being like 5 or 6 years old going to the
Ringling Brothers Circus I think it was
at Madison Square Garden at the time in
New York City and seeing the elephants I
thought it was like the coolest freakin
thing that these giant animals were in
the same room as us that said this is
probably a good thing right we've all
heard these insane stories about how
they treat these animals and elephants
are incredibly smart and sensitive and
probably should not be in these circuses
right right I mean yeah they have
horrible methods of getting them to do
tricks they like poke them with hard
metal objects and stuff and that's sad I
mean it but this is only elephants
they've got other animals too they've
got like tigers and lions and what about
them and bears oh my
why is it bears no I mean I you know
it's the kind of first thought I had I
was like what about all the other
animals but I mean it's a good start
yeah so let's start with that point then
like does this ultimately lead to them
getting rid of all the animals and then
and then do you lose something about
what's so fun about the circus I mean
yeah you lose the element of cruel okay
I am
I've been against the circus I've
actually been the protester outside
really for years now I think it's
horrible it's atrocious what they do
these animals I see you're talking about
for all that is video and the fact that
honestly the fact that elephants are
finally being phased out is amazing but
you're a hundred percent right there's
still you know tigers lions I think they
have even other animals and they had
like snow tigers and things like that
those are also endangered animals so I
you know I'm glad the elephants are
being phased out but at the same token
these other animals are not being
affected any less by this you know and
and also I don't like that they're being
phased out just eliminate them it's it's
been past this right I mean this reminds
me of the New York City carriage horse
situation where they've been trying to
phase them out and now it sounds like
the Blasio is gonna make it happen but
it's like if you really want to end it
just end it and those horses as bad as
the elephants are treated to me those
horses in the middle of those cars they
can't see anything like it's and they
get hit by cars and all that do you guys
find it easier to sympathize with
animals than humans sometimes like I
definitely get that feeling like if I
see a stray dog like in the street I
feel terrible I want to do something and
yet all the time in LA you see homeless
people you see crazy people and drug
addicts and it's almost like I don't
feel that much I know that sounds sick
but it's true well I mean animals have
an innocence about them you know that
you know people maybe have done
something bad to put them in a bad
situation but you don't always know that
like I feel bad for any anything that's
like victimized in any way yeah so yeah
do you feel it with animals I don't know
what it is yeah oh you're well you're a
big you rescue dogs and you have like 87
cats yeah 14 lizards I'm an armadillo
no I there's something that's always
really pulled at my heartstrings with
animals yeah like you said there it's
this innocent there unspoken for and I
just really identify with them I don't
know I just want to protect them and
yeah with humans you don't know their
story I mean if I see a child of course
tree or something or an elder you know
then obviously it has a similar reaction
but you know if you're an able-bodied
human I have just less nach
you know empathy towards you for that
right so I think most of us feel that
even though we the person could have
mental problems that we don't know about
but right if you see like a 30-something
you're all guy there are people that
stand in the middle of La Cienega like
you know trying to get to California
even though they're in California you
know like alright you don't feel much
sympathy for them because you sort of
feel like it's their fault where I know
it's not always their fault of course
but animals they can you know and I've
never seen like maybe if you threw like
a Sarah McLaughlin sign behind ya I saw
him behind like you know mine's like
people I would feel the same but there's
something about like those eyes and like
I don't I just really wait where do you
send people to adopt dogs and stuff
don't you
I mean there's there's a couple now God
now come on if you want to adopt an
elephant where do you go oh my god now
I'm totally blanking because they're so
do it yes all right go to where I got my
dog at least in New York the Humane
Society of New York it's not part of a
bigger humane society but the humane
society itself is pretty good how do you
guys feel about zoos in general cuz I
went to the San Diego Zoo about a year
ago and I got like a really super
private tour and I was in there with the
elephants I literally like under them
and like washing their bellies and doing
all this cool stuff and feeding giraffes
and everything but I did leave even
though it was awesome it was really
awesome and seeing these animals and all
that I did leave kind of feeling sad for
them like especially like the lions and
tigers where they were just sitting
there like you know like how do you
generally even though I know they're
doing a ton of good stuff at the zoo in
there rehabilitating animals and you
know endangered species and all that
yeah and I always feel bad to see an
animal in a cage no matter what yeah
it's hard because like you know people
use the argument well they're being
taken care of they're giving all the
special treatment and I hear the same
thing from my family that is very much
into horse racing you know they're like
well the horses have this better life
they're being taken care of them like
yeah but they break their leg and
they're euthanized right away you know
so it's like the higher quality of being
cared for and stuff I in my opinion
isn't as valuable it's just letting them
be you know themselves in the wild right
22 of course because you know the
endangered lion that's my tree
well loses its desire to live in some
ways and is bored yet at the same time
isn't under the threat of being poached
or something so I mean you could say
like if you go visit a prison they're
being taken care of you know they're
protecting being protected from society
etc etc it's the same thing in zoos
unless it's a wildlife protection you
know refuge or there's something like
that
I think zoos for the most part are
something that should also be eliminated
as well as you know like places like
SeaWorld absolutely I mean you are
actually seeing physical responses to
captivity with you know their fins going
down with elephants pacing back and
forth yeah and they're literally going
mad and then they wonder why every now
and again one of these answers does
something and then what they do they get
euthanized yeah all right so more
importantly than any of this when will
they free the clowns yes good they're
just gonna open a little car you want
the class to be free too here okay the
clowns people all right should we free
the clowns let us know in the comments
right down below gee whiz this is a wild
story we're streaming in the quest for
renewable energy some ideas are right
here than others but this one may take
the cake
this p-power toilet converts urine into
electricity and might just be crazy
enough to work the hope is that the
power will be used to light toilets and
refugee camps where women are at
heightened risk of sexual assault during
the night the toilets use microbial fuel
cell that converts microbes into fuel
thus light in the cabin as one release
themselves science is pretty awesome
right like pretty cool is the kind of
thing you're like wow science man it
works it actually works it's tested and
it works yes I've never really thought
of doing something like this but that if
they can make pee you know turn into
electricity that's a pretty badass
yeah of all things that I think about
that never crossed my mind yes yeah so
we can turn pee into electricity we did
a story a couple weeks ago about a bus
in the UK being powered by poop Wow yeah
so I need to go back and check on that
one yeah so we're just batteries we're
just pee poop
I love the matrix I love that I am a
little bit concerned about this this
situation though like lighting you know
the the refugee camps and things like
that the bathrooms because I feel like
is it gonna have a backlash where it's
just kind of like light like lighting up
the area where the women are going you
know I'm saying we're not sure what
you're saying no but I'm I'm saying like
okay so these women it's this is used to
protect the women Yeah right
yeah but I'm these people the men don't
seem to really care in general though
they kind of don't care if they're
assaulting like it's not like a hidden
thing like this is happening a lot so
what I'm saying is if it's a lit up area
don't you feel like they'll be like oh
look at all the women we're going to the
bathroom late at night right look at all
those gang women those are only light up
when they're going pee - like oh no well
I like you I found the toilet and I'm
paying okay well there's a light so
you're you think it's possible that the
electricity's only working while the pee
is actually I think they somehow store
the pee in there yeah Betty gives you
like that and the thing is it's also if
the men don't know the women are going
to the bathroom and then they go to the
bathroom and then it lights up is that
just like a giant advertisement like I'm
here not only not only to watch them but
like to like oh now I can go find my
yeah do you think it's kind of
interesting that they're starting to do
this in places like this I feel like
this is the type of thing if they said
to people in San Francisco or to people
in LA like you can power your house with
your pee and poop I think a lot of
people would do it then why not it saves
some money right and my people love well
it's good for the environment would you
do it and think about it but it's it's
it's limitless really like you could
have bars like fully powered by all the
people that were using their bathrooms
from all
be drinking their entire electric greg
could be powered by this so this is kind
of future right this reminds me of like
there's a couple gems that like are
actually some of the electricity is
actually powered by the people that are
on the treadmills this is like the
future of technology right I mean I
think it's a pretty awesome invention
like why not it's something that would
just be wasted yeah and now it's being
used to create something that would have
used resources yeah you know why do you
guys think we're so fearful of bodily
functions like everyone loves fart jokes
we did the poop bus story and made a
zillion puns like but this is natural
stuff why does that still like is it
just like our four-year-old self is
still acting out oh yeah I think it's
totally that like although I totally
embraced Freud jokes and bodily function
wholeheartedly oh you brought us home
with a bang what do you guys think pee
for electricity poop powered buses is
the future gonna be crappy let us know
in the comments right down below if you
thought Rick and Daryl had issues with
the walking dead take a look at this for
most of us when our loved ones die they
are laid to rest for eternity not so for
one community in Indonesia in a ceremony
called the cleaning of the corpses
families raised their deceased relatives
from their graves dress them in new
clothes fix their hair and repair their
coffins then they walk the dead around
the province so they can observe at the
living okay so as Westerners that
actually seems kind of hard to believe
but after I read the story and I was
thinking about a little bit more we have
pretty bonkers practices related to
death - right my grandma one of them got
cremated I mean they literally just
burned her body to ash the other one was
buried traditionally but like I saw her
in a coffin and dressed up like we do
these weird things so really is this
practice any weirder I know viscerally
there's something about it yeah it's are
pretty weird every year to dig them up
and dress them up and walk them around
and like that's a little bit different
than observing in a coffin er yeah some
like final respect that you pay to
someone this is like an ongoing like dig
them up and carry them around and this
just right
the walking around would seem to me to
be the like I can guess like I'm really
I'm trying to be open-minded about this
like they have their traditions that's
that's great
so dressing them up that's one thing but
they really they're like parading them
around like it there seems to be like
there would be health issues or
something right yeah I would think well
also I just don't understand how it's
physically possible in some senses like
the malleability factor I sure would
start going down at a pretty rapid pace
you know like how our limbs cracking
after they just attach them back on
right it must be much more fun to play
with like a newer dad and how long do
you continue doing it like do you just
eventually just kind of carry like a
bushel of their bones around town right
with like a hat on top perhaps that's
really creepy
right I mean I don't know at what point
they stopped but I just don't understand
also how they actually get the clothes
on without them crumbling to pieces when
I first pulled up the article I actually
thought that woman I was a whoa for
making one last hoorah around town yeah
what do you guys think about like the
general fascination with zombies I feel
like zombies are in like a little
Renaissance right now Walking Dead
there's like five other shows I always
love zombies from when I was a kid and
they want to eat our brains you like
your brain what's going on I I mean I
think it's interesting it's you know
like a fantasy type of thing if vampires
and zombies and you know people like to
believe in or you know be entertained by
these things but like it's not literal
this is the walking right yeah you think
it's more about like the zombies
themselves or it's just like the
fascination is more about just like this
apocalyptic yeah we're obsessed with the
end of the world I think any apocalyptic
thing but I also think like it's
supernatural or whatever you want to
call it creatures kind of make waves in
terms of popularity like vampire
had their huge day yeah werewolves had
their little blip of a thing then and
succeeded as much as Dom bees are now
really taking over right so we had like
True Blood gave us we're on that
everything
Twilight then a little with a little
you're a little werewolf and now we're
on the zombies what's next aliens
started off with like x-files I think
aliens need to make a comeback right or
it could be just be like clones of Will
Smith's kids oh that would be a hard if
if they brought you guys back after you
were dead how would you want to be
dressed would you be dressed like
yourself now or would you want to just
really go over the top I think I'll be
cremated to make sure that can never
happen I don't want to be cremated yeah
yeah you want to well they have these
actually really cool things where you
can be cremated and then put into like a
pot yes and then like a tree will grow
did we yes did I do this story with you
no I just I've seen that everywhere
that's cool yeah I'll be a tree so there
literally is something there doing it I
think it started in Portland I can't
remember what it's called uh Pam but
they literally will take your remains
put it into a garden and then like your
family you can eat like mint I just feel
like a non edible tree yeah
all right last thought on this is there
something about this story that's
actually kind of beautiful like I know
it's also it seems kind of silly we can
joke about it but like just how
different humans are all over the place
and that we all have our different
traditions or whatever works out there's
something kind of beautiful that this
well I mean I think that there I think
there is you know they're celebrating
life whereas I feel like in in this
culture we kind of we tend to you know
more knit which is natural you know
mourning loss but I think you know we
put a lot of sadness behind it and
they're putting celebration and we do
weird [ __ ] with it we filled them up
with formaldehyde we make them look like
living dolls I mean it's very weird
at least this they're you know taking
them in their naturally decrepit remains
and great do you feel that but there's
something like just interesting about
how we are the
tons of us on this planet we all kind of
deal with it differently yeah that's
that's whatever makes them happy
whatever makes you dead people happy
anyway what do you think is this creepy
is it cool let us know in the comments
right down below and thanks for watching
I'm now gonna let you to pimp yourselves
out
talk to the camera right over there
where you go alright you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at whitney
mixter la I am everything is the same
Jacquelyn Glen Twitter Instagram
Facebook so buy me yeah and this is the
Reuben report I'll even talk over here
this is the room where you can follow me
on twitter at Reuben report oh and by
the way if you dig my cool red chair a
lot of people have been commenting on it
it's from apartment to be calm that's
apt to the number be calm and if you use
code Reuben report you get 10% off
anything on the site holy cow
anyway thanks guys for doing this and we
will be back